[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à toutes et à tous
je vous présente mon éléphant
alors c'est de lui que vais vous parler
aujourd'hui fait mon éléphant pas que
lui aussi de tous ces éléphants que j'ai
devant moi
ces mastodontes qu'il ya derrière chacun
et chacune de nous et si je vous assure
on en a tous un mais bon on en parlera
plus tard trêve d'éléphants tri c'est
aussi une histoire de claques première
claque
j'ai 21 ans je veux aux pays-bas
programme erasmus
je rends compte pas mal de gens qui
viennent d'un peu partout dans le monde
et je me fais deux amis raphaël et
nicolas ensemble on se pose à peu près
les mêmes questions sur le monde
l'avenir
quelle place on pourrait y jouer on se
fait un marathon de documentaires sur le
mystère des pyramides égyptiennes le
réchauffement climatique ou encore les
attentats du 11 septembre
un même constat si on veut changer le
monde si on veut faire en sorte que les
choses aillent mieux
c'est pas en mettant en place une
ampoule de basse consommation ou en
fermant l'eau du robinet quand on se
brosse les dents
il faut faire un vrai sacrifice on
apprend que 50 % des gaz à effet de
serre viennent de la production de
viande
raphaël en entendant ça il est allemand
devient végétarien dans l'eure pour moi
c'est un peu plus compliqué j'aime les
hamburgers j'essaye de trouver toutes
les excuses possibles et imaginables
pour continuer à manger de la viande la
conscience tranquille
en vain j'ai vu quelques images qui me
dérange
j'ai du mal finalement je franchis le
pas je me jette à cette époque là mon
éléphant est de taille plutôt modeste
quand même assez fier parce que je suis
étudiant à l'étranger et parce que je
viens de devenir végétarien deuxième
claque à force de voir deux
documentaires on se fait une vocation
on se dit on pourrait faire pareil si on
faisait un grand voyage super écologique
sans argent pour ne rien consommer en
auto stop en bateau stop jusqu'au
mexique
alors là on se dit aussi qu'on pourrait
faire un grand documentaire et montrer
au monde entier comment est ce qu'on
peut vivre différemment
je vous dis pas la taille de mon
éléphant à ce moment-là et celui de mes
deux comparses ça se demandait comment
on a fait pour entrer dans la première
voiture le fait ce qu'on a envie de
changer le monde sur le papier mais la
réalité est tout autre
dès le départ grosse galère on se
retrouve à dormir dans des stations
essence dans des cages d'escalier a
grelotté jusqu'au petit matin
affamé parce qu'on n'a aucune idée de
comment récupérer de la nourriture là
avec mon éléphant je fais pas le malin
je me dis c'est bien de vouloir changer
le monde avec des idées anti
consumériste faudrait peut-être bien
commencé à apprendre à se débrouiller
tout seul 3e claque en espagne rencontre
des anarchistes qui nous initie à l'art
de la récup pour se nourrir et du squat
âge pour dormir mais au maroc
c'est une autre histoire y'a pas de
poubelle quand on demande les invite les
invendus on nous invite systématiquement
à manger
pareil pour l'auto stop ça fonctionne à
merveille mais les conducteurs ne
peuvent pas s'empêcher nous inviter chez
eux pour dormir
comme ce coup il ya ce marocain qui nous
trouvent en plein milieu de la nuit
il nous invite chez lui et il insiste
pour que nous restions trois jours dans
son appartement pendant que lui et sa
femme enceinte vont chez ses
beaux-parents au troisième matin il
débarque dans l'appart les gars ça y est
je suis papa il est où vous il nous
emmène à l'hôpital et il insiste pour
que nous prenions le bébé dans nos bras
pour lui on est un peu comme les trois
mages venus annoncer la naissance de son
fils et l'appelle d'ailleurs y arias
l'élu le fait c'est qu'on prend une
vraie leçon de générosité au maroc mais
c'était pas nous qui étions censés
montrer au monde comment est-ce qu'on
pouvait vivre différemment je fais pas
le fier mon éléphant non plus j'ai
l'impression que ce que je fais c'est
pas vraiment juste je en train de
profiter je vis sur le dos des autres je
ne vis pas sans argent
les marocains balaie tout ça d'un revers
de main ils me disent machy mouche qu'il
situe peut recevoir reçoit tu donneras
quand tu pourras quatrième claque je
commence à voir les joues rouges
on trouve un belge qui nous emmène
d'agadir jusqu'aux îles canaries là on
passe un mois et demi alors on a trouvé
un squat pour dormir on va faire les
poubelles des supermarchés pour nous
nourrir et tous les jours on va au port
à la recherche d'un bateau
coup de chance on tombe sur deux
capitaines italien qui avait justement
mis une annonce et alors c'est véridique
cherche deux femmes blondes de
préférence pour faire la traversée
jusqu'au brésil
alors je sais pas s'il ya des femmes
blondes dans l'assemblée mais ils ont
trouvé personne étrangement essec no3
barbe finalement qu'ils embarquent à
bord c'est plutôt relax on cuisine on
nettoie on astique on prend nos car
pendant la nuit
on a surtout beaucoup de temps pour
penser pour prendre un petit peu de
recul sur cette expérience
- raphaël on est assez extatique on a
l'impression d'avoir trouvé le saint
graal la solution pour changer le monde
l'argent est le problème si on s'en
passe tout va aller mieux
on part dans des grands discours le soir
nos éléphants ce fonds énormes
le bateau commençait à chavirer nos deux
capitaines salle et soul un petit peu il
nous rappelle quand même que si on fait
la traversée c'est parce que eux ont
tout financer les tensions montent et il
est temps de débarquer 5e claque on
arrive au brésil dans la ville de recife
qui porte très bien son nom
je pense qu'on peut dire que nous
échouons plus qu'autre chose il y a des
centaines de gens qui dorment à même la
rue le jour il écume les poubelles on
trouve rien à se mettre sous la dent un
soir on trouve quand même un petit
refuge pour passer la nuit
mais on nous réveille en plein milieu de
la nuit et on nous menace de mort
pour nicolas c'est un peu trop il décide
d'arrêter l'aventuré ne peut plus
continuer raphaël et moi même on est un
peu aveugle
on n'est pas du tout à l'écouté avec nos
gros éléphant c'est un coup dur mais on
essaye de l'oublier non on va continuer
coûte que coûte on ira jusqu'au mexique
et on reprend la route à 2 un peu plus
loin on se retrouve bloqué dans une
station essence
c'est notre karma un jour deux jours
trois jours quatre jours
franchement je vous le dis j'ai vraiment
envie d'arrêter j'aimerais abandonné le
voyage à ce moment là mais je peux pas
on n'arrive même pas revenir en arrière
heureusement rencontre un camionneur qui
accepte de nous laisser dormir à
l'arrière de son camion
en prime il nous invite à manger jour de
fête
là j'ai le sentiment que tout va aller
mieux mais au petit matin sur froide je
me réveille mais affaires ont disparu là
c'est la panique
je sors du camion je vais dans les
stations essence je cherche quelqu'un
responsable en disant qu'ils me donnent
au moins mon passeport et à ce moment là
je me rends compte que c'est en fait le
camionneur kim avait dérobé je le vois
partir avec son camion et je me retrouve
avec une paire de sandales un short et
un tee shirt mon éléphant là je crois
qu'il est complètement désintégrée et
justement grâce à ça je vois peut-être
un petit peu plus clair d'un coup je me
rends compte que ça fait des mois que je
bassine tout le monde sur cette idée de
sans argent mais j'avais un sac à dos et
deux dans une carte bancaire dissimulé
dans une poche secrète
je me dis qu'au final j'avais peut-être
bien chercher ce vrai dépouillement
désormais j'étais vraiment ce que je
prétendais être un voyageur sans argent
claque numéro 6 on remonte en guyane je
refais mon passeport
nous longeons la con la côte jusqu'en
colombie nous traversons l'amérique
centrale et arrivons enfin au mexique
la copine de raphaël qui nous avait
rejoints tombe enceinte et il décide de
rentrer en allemagne
je me retrouve seul je m'intègre à des
mouvements écologistes mexicain lamont
éléphants comme vous pouvez le voir il
s'est refait une belle santé
désormais je suis à la flotte shooter
qui a fait trente mille kilomètres sans
argent mois superstar
j'écrase littéralement tout le monde
autour de moi j'essaye de monter plein
de projets à chaque fois je ça va pas
assez vite
pas assez loin je m'énerve je m'agace et
au final au bout du compte je me
retrouve seule avec mon éléphant
je commence à comprendre que quelque
chose ne va pas coup de chance je
rencontre un français qui sort de
vipassana vipassana c'est un centre de
méditation on peut méditer pendant dix
jours dix heures par jour et en silence
et en plus c'est gratuit
je fonce sur l'occasion à bip à sanaa
j'apprends à calmer mon esprit je
m'appelle ça me permet aussi de prendre
un petit peu de recul sur tout ce qui
s'est passé
vipassana ça veut dire observer la
réalité telle qu'elle est là je me rends
compte que pendant tout ce temps là je
m'étais focaliser sur le changement
changer les autres changer nos modes de
consommation ont changé et cetera et
cetera
mais je n'avais pas bien pris le temps
d'observer le monde tel qu'il était de
l'embrasser comme il était et encore
moins de l'accepter là c'est la grosse
claque du voyage je me rends compte que
j'étais dans l'erreur tout ce temps là
c'est aussi à ce moment là que je prends
conscience de mon éléphant
oui j'ai un mastodonte derrière moi très
utile il m'a permis d'avancer il m'a
permis de faire ce voyage de braver les
obstacles le moment de commencer quelque
chose de collectif
ça devient un obstacle là c'est moi en
train de méditer 7e claque
yasmine une adorable petite mexicaine
nous tombons amoureux et nous décidons
de faire la route ensemble
alors avec elle mon éléphant doit se
faire encore un petit peu plus petit
pour faire de la place à son l'éléphant
elle
je m'adapte je change pour quelqu'un
d'autre
c'est une grosse révolution pas complète
cependant on n'a pas envie de laisser
tomber cette histoire de vie sans argent
nous aussi qu'on pourrait la rendre plus
pérenne et si on faisait un éco village
sans argent l'idée m'en chante on hésite
entre le mexique et la france pour
finalement choisir l'hexagone si le
monde est dans cet état là c'est surtout
à cause des européens c'est là qu'il
faut agir nous tendons nos pouces
direction la floride et ses voiliers
deux mois plus tard yasmine est en
pleurs on nous interdit l'accès au port
on doit se cacher de la police pour
trouver un coin pour dormir et on est en
famille helm implore de prendre l'avion
pour rentrer en france
l'avion je sais qu'à eu un speech un peu
plus tôt qu'à dit que au final envoyer
des mails ou faire des recherches google
ça pollue et plus que l'avion mais pour
moi à ce moment là l'écolo chevronnés
que je suis sait pas moyen mon éléphant
se dressent de toute sa hauteur
mon empreinte écologique ne peut pas
monter en flèche comme ça mais face à
lui à l'amour je suis terriblement
amoureux et du coup je cède nous faisons
stop jusqu'à new york nous montons dans
l'avion et 7 heures plus tard je me
retrouve en france j'avais mis onze mois
pour faire l'aller là mon éléphant
je sais pas où il est je crois qu'il va
pas passer le portique de l'aéroport et
j'arrive en france par la petite porte
je suis pas le mec sans argent avec mon
étiquette chéri qui en impose à tout le
monde
je suis juste quelqu'un comme les autres
qui a envie d'un monde meilleur et qui
sait pas forcément trop comment faire
je me rends compte que pour commencer un
projet collectif c'est pas plus mal
huitième claque on retrouve rafael sa
copine et leurs enfants
on décide de faire le projet ensemble et
on l'appelle et autopia en chemin vers
l'utopie
on trouve un groupe de 23 personnes et
on trouve même un terrain de 17 hectares
dans le sud de la france alors là moi je
vais à nouveau bon ça y est cette fois
ci c'est le projet qui peut changer le
monde
on va pouvoir montrer au monde comment
est ce qu'on peut vivre différemment
plus écologiquement mon éléphant s'est
refait une belle santé et je pense que
ce discours ne vous est pas étranger et
encore une fois je déchante assez vite
sur les vingt-trois personnes y en a que
trois qui restent sur le terrain avec
moi les autres ont besoin de plus de
confort et elmer aussi et pas très
enchanté de voir une bande de hippies
débarquer sur ses terres il nous
interdit le permis de construire
l'hiver arrive et je me retrouve seule
avec yasmine enceinte 9e claque ada ma
fille arrive au monde
le lendemain de l'accouchement je vais
dans un magasin et pour la première fois
en cinq ans j'achète des choses c'est
très perturbant comme expérience pour
moi d'un coup j'ai le choix je peux
prendre des choses que je veux les
mettre dans un sac
elle est payée avec de l'argent très
perturbant mais j'y attache pas trop
d'importance quand même je me rappelle
de la sagesse des marocains qui m'avait
dit qu'il n'y a pas de vrai changement
sans lâcher prise je lâche prise alors
sur mes convictions mes idéaux et je me
concentre sur les nécessités vitales de
ma fille est étrangement l'horizon
s'éclaircit mon éléphant a fait de la
place pour un petit bout de chou qui
tient dans la main
un fermier nous contacter il a 11
hectares trois bâtiments deux sources il
a envie de faire le projet avec nous là
malheureusement mon éléphant il se
regonflent d'un coup le projet autopia
n'est pas mort je peux encore changer le
monde je peux encore montré aux autres
comment est ce qu'on peut faire les
choses différemment
je saute sur l'occasion le fermier
cependant à des attentes et aussi
quelques problèmes économiques
je ne veux rien savoir pour moi le
projet de se faire sans argent sans ceci
sans cela je suis une porte fermée
pétri de bonnes intentions mais fermé
quand même au bout de deux mois le
projet capote
je me retrouve à nouveau seul ou presque
avec yasmine courageuse qui me soutient
et notre fille 10e claque c'est la
dernière
enfin je m'en serais je m'en suis pris
plein d'autres et je m'en prends encore
mais pour ce soir ce sera la seule que
je vais vous raconter je sais pas ce qui
se passe avec ce projet j'ai
l'impression que tout va bien sur le
papier on a envie de changer le monde on
a plein d'idées géniales
sans argent ouvert à tous quel est le
problème yasmine me donne une piste
peut-être que je suis trop attaché à
cette idée de sans argent on pourrait
demander à des gens de nous aider quoi
pour moi il n'y a pas moyen
si j'ai fait tout ce voyage si je suis
ce que je suis à ce moment là c'est
parce que j'ai arrêté utiliser de
l'argent j'y crois dur comme fer
si je suis une bonne personne c'est
grâce à ça mais je vois yasmine et
surtout je vois à d'un autre fille qui
commence à faire ses premiers pas
valdinguer d'un endroit à un autre
je me dis qu'elle mérite quand même un
endroit pour grandir et je me résigne à
ce moment là deux personnes au contact
et ils peuvent nous avancer des fonds
pour acheter un lieu pour que le projet
existe je l'aï pris sur cette conviction
qui me construisait au je pensais que
c'était celle qui me construise est et
l'horizon s'éclaircit à nouveau
aujourd'hui le projet autopia existe ça
fait deux ans nous avons sept résidents
bientôt 10 nous ne vivons pas sans
argent nous faisons plein de choses cool
que je peux pas vous raconter maintenant
ce qui a pas le temps mais le fait est
que nous ne vivons pas sans argent je
n'ai pas l'empreinte écologique aussi
basse que ce que j'aurais aimé nous
avons l'électricité l'internet nous
prenons la voiture pour faire des
courses mais nous sommes plusieurs à
expérimenter ensemble mon éléphant
a repris une taille modeste pour pouvoir
cohabiter avec les éléphants d autres
personnes
je n'ai jamais eu autant le sentiment
d'avancer
pour finir j'aimerais revenir sur mon
éléphant
enfin sur vos éléphants sur nos
éléphants à tous d'ailleurs je sais pas
pour ce qu'ont compris à ce que d'après
vous qu'est ce que c'est qu'un éléphant
ouais exactement c'est l'ego alors
jusque légaux pour moi c'est un truc que
j'ai jamais vraiment compris notion très
abstraite et j'aime bien l'image de mon
patxi derme qui m'empêche de passer par
les portes qui sont déjà grande ouverte
le fait c'est qu'on a tous quelque chose
comme ça derrière nous qui peut prendre
des proportions plus ou moins grande
suivant la situation et qu'ils soient
gonflés d'écologie de bien-être animal
de solidarité internationale ou encore
de finance de capitalisme d'un beat
d'individualisme à tes souhaits c'est un
peu de choses près la même chose
c'est très utile d'avoir un éléphant
pour avancer dans la vie pour faire face
à ce monde qui est quand même souvent
hostile de s'entourer de conviction
d'être fiers mais au moment de
construire quelque chose de collectif
pour faire les choses ensemble pour
mettre en place un changement à
plusieurs ce que j'ai surtout appris
c'est que c'était nécessaire d'apprendre
à se dégonfler
merci
[Applaudissements]